[Musique]
depuis la basilique notre dame de
fourvière à lyon
l'église catholique regarde ses fidèles
de haut il est puissant diocèse de lyon
depuis 2002 son chef c'est le cardinal
philippe barbarin en ce moment lyon est
frappé par un énorme scandale de
pédophilie
le diocèse l'église de france et même le
vatican sont accusés d'avoir tout fait
pour l'étouffer de 70 500 jeunes scouts
de 8 à 12 ans ont été agressées
sexuellement
certains violée par leurs aumôniers le
père bernard prénat le prédateur un
homme charismatique et respecté a sévi
pendant au moins 20 ans dans le silence
le plus complet de l'église et ses
fidèles
l'omerta si on a un qui a pas bougé sur
cette question là depuis le départ c'est
moi tout le monde a bougé d'église
l'état le législateur la justice c'était
sans compter sur la ténacité de cet
homme françois devaux et de deux autres
victimes de l'aumônier leur organisation
la parole libérée a servi de forum à
toutes les victimes du père prenne à
celui ci a reconnu tous ses crimes il
aura son procès normalement en 2019
même s'il résiste au jugement sous
prétexte de prescription la sphère
prénat est devenue la sphère barbara
parce que le cardinal a dit ceci pour la
majorité des jets grâce à dieu sont
prescrits des paroles maladroites
aussitôt regretté mais qui ont donné
leurs titres à ce film de françois ozon
présenté au festival de cinéma de berlin
grâce à dieu
sont confrontés à des ses anciens et
grâce à dieu tous ces faits sont
prescrits
il est en ce moment présenté aux
victimes en avant première grâce à dieu
ça veut dire heureusement le cardinal
barbarin avec plusieurs autres
personnalités du diocèse ont été jugés
suite à la plainte de la parole libérée
pour non dénonciation de crime pédophile
la paroisse saint luc se trouve dans le
faubourg plutôt bourgeois de sainte foy
les lyon
le père bernard lhez sur pied à
saint-luc une troupe scoute mixte
c'est un as de l'organisation les
parents l'adorent personne ne voit rien
surtout pas les petites filles jusqu'à
2015 près ce que je pouvais dire que
c'était parmi mes souvenirs d'enfance et
plus heureux isabelle de gaulmyn a fait
partie de la troupe pendant quatre ans
en 2005 un prêtre lui confie ce site m'a
dit c'est horrible sur le père prenne à
ya un énorme dossier dans le diocèse
ce type est un salopard quand il m'a dit
ça moi j'en ai parlé en cr barbarin en
2005 en disant vous savez on sait faire
il ya un truc un peu embêtant là
par rapport aux pères prennent à que moi
j'ai connu petit je sais pas où il est
maintenant mais je crois qu'il ya des
grosses casseroles
voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai dit est de
fait après je m'en suis plus du tout
occupé en 2015 je me suis je m'en suis
beaucoup mieux je me suis dit mais il ya
dix ans les choses devaient pas
prescrite j'aurais pu faire une enquête
j'aurais pu aller plus loin et en fait
j'ai rien fait parce que à l'époque bas
un peu comme beaucoup de catholiques je
n'ai pas tellement envie de fouiller en
fin de compte
car c'est en 2015 que le scandale éclate
il retombe sur le cardinal barbarin en
2015 et qu'ils vont voir
finalement il fait il tarde beaucoup à
réagir il montre déjà il montre pas
d'empathie 1 ce qui est ce qu'elle est
ce qu'on va très bien ont filmé ce qui
est révoltant et puis plutôt que de dire
victime je suis à vos côtés ça a été
celle de réflexe de protéger
on a étudié d'autres cas de prêtres du
diocèse de lyon qui eux aussi ont été
couverts on l'a écrit dans nos articles
par le cardinal barbarin ce qu'on a
publié sur médiapart c'est quand ou non
seulement le père prenne à a été couvert
selon nous mais quatre autres prêtres du
diocèse de lyon
dieu c'est dommage c'est que prennent à
est un prédateur sexuel depuis les
années 60 tous on se savait que prennent
a déjà au petit séminaire avait des
déviants sexuels et ça c'est un cas le
cap reina mais en fait si on a plein
d'autres et avait plein d'autres à lyon
et à plein d'autres en france et il ya
plein d'autres monde entier
le procès pour non dénonciation dure
trois jours les avocats de monseigneur
barbarin plaide la prescription des
faits et la non responsabilité directe
il a fallu finalement un procès pour que
les victimes puissent être écouté par le
par l'archevêque dans leur douleur leur
souffrance etc
et puis pour que l'archevêque
reconnaissent humaine d'ailleurs à ce
procès qui fait des erreurs de gestion
des erreurs de gestion mais pas de fond
la parole libérée
en fait tu as déjà gagné son procès quel
que soit le jugement qui sera rendu le 7
mars
parce que il ya eu un moment de vérité
quelque part et ça a été médiatisé
énormément et c'est ce moment là en fait
que les victimes attendaient au sein de
l'église
un seul prêtre a osé demander la
démission de monseigneur barbara comment
ça se fait qu'un pasteur qui aurait dû
être du côté du vide des victimes se
retrouvent finalement du côté du
prédateur pour sa pétition qui a
recueilli plus de cent mille signatures
le curé vignes ont été sanctionnés il a
perdu sa fonction de juge ecclésiastique
du diocèse
quant au pardon pour toutes les affaires
de pédophilie
monseigneur barbarin l'a demandé mais en
même temps que tous les évêques de
france à lourdes en 2016
nous n'avons pas toujours fait ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire voilà nous n'avons
pas toujours et l'attention aux victimes
nous n'avons pas toujours mesurer ce que
ce que la souffrance des victimes ce que
cela représentait pour elle 2 commission
denquête ont été constitués une part
l'église et l'autre par le sénat ces
actions au plus tôt ses réactions
les catholiques de france le doivent à
la parole libérée
samedi après-midi maintenait dans le
local photo de la paroisse et puis il ya
le fil grâce à dieu on a été pris comme
ça n'en a pas un tourbillon et que ce
film c'est l'apogée du tourbillon
je pense que ça va avoir un impact non
négligeable que c'est une pierre
monumental
une de plus mais une grosse pierre